hello welcome back to overwatch hero
guides I'm Daniel Dwyer joined by Chris
waters Chris I remember months ago Jeff
Kaplan saying that a team with Symetra
had a higher chance of winning than a
team without as a measure one of those
characters not a lot of people pick very
early on but incredibly powerful if you
have somebody who's able to utilize her
properly so useful and the most obvious
way she's useful is the teleporter
that's her ultimate once you've got that
charged up throwing down the teleporter
so your team doesn't have to run from a
spawn point really helps tip the odds in
your favor so you want to put that thing
somewhere that's not right on the
frontlines it's around a corner it's
somewhere where there aren't long sight
lines and so the enemy team doesn't spot
it and also be careful when you put it
down there's a little Chevron pointing
that's the way that people are going to
come out so you want to point that
towards the front don't point it towards
the wall or you're going to end up with
a lot of confused teammates and just a
little tidbit of information there that
teleporter it's only good for 6
teleports so make sure you've got your
team covered with nothing eventually
goes down another one of Symmetry's
abilities are her sentry turrets she's
able to create a bunch of these on the
very handy for trapping people
especially when they walk in doorways
absolutely there you can put down six of
these things and you always want to have
all six out in the field no question you
want to put a few around your teleporter
that's a good way to sort of deter
people who actually get up close because
it takes a few shots to destroy a
teleporter and if they're getting
hassled by a turret they might run off a
little bit earlier but putting these
turrets down behind doors up above on
walls and around corners places where
your enemies can't really see them until
they're getting turreted is a real great
way to just add a little bit of chaos to
the battlefield because even though they
don't do a heck of a lot of damage they
are a nuisance they can kill people
especially people who are fleeing the
main fight because they're low on health
you pick them off of the turret Oh feels
so good so much of course a support
character so she has got a buff the
photon shield adds a little bit of
shield damage to every person I'm
guessing you just you should be like
doling these out like pills just always
have it at any time you'll see a prompt
on an ally if they don't have shields
just press that button and you'll shield
them up it can make a big difference
especially with a squishier character
like Zenyatta or some of your offense
players and every time you see so-and-so
has used your teleporter you know
there's a new ally
that's respawned that needs your shields
talk to me a little bit about her photon
projector her gone it's got two
different modes which one should you be
using and when yes so you can charge it
up and it shoots this big slow-moving
Enter
jebal or you can use it as a beam weapon
and it needs to attach to an enemy to do
that damage and they need to be pretty
close so if someone catches you
off-guard if someone is flanking that's
probably when you're going to do the
beam thing and once you've attached it
to them you don't need to be aiming at
them to fire so you should be jumping
all around them you should be running
back and forth through them make it
harder for them to hit you because you
are going to be draining their health
the whole time and also you know you
don't have a ton of health so you want
to be staying nimble charge shots though
those things you should just basically
be always firing those down the main
lane especially at a Reinhardt because
Reinhardt shield blocks a lot of
projectiles it does not block your
charged shot and so you can really start
to damage a Reinhardt and discourage him
from sitting on the point like he loves
to do for sure it does a payload coming
at you as well it's a great little you
know place to sort of love a couple of
balls in there because people are just
standing on it thinking that they're
protected especially by Reinhardt shield
let's talk about some of the people you
should stay away from isometric
obviously you're sort of decent a little
bit about protecting yourself but who
are the people who when you sort of meet
up with the media to get the hell out of
Dodge
you really don't want to be facing off
against a Hanzo or a Widowmaker someone
who can pick you off from a distance as
in yatta that's going to be trouble for
you your best engagements are close
range and also running into an area that
you have put your turrets in right as
the more Norbert turret time you've got
on people you're going to drain their
health you're also going to distract
them that turret is like emits a loud
buzzing noise you it really distracting
and don't underestimate the power of
that distraction you know throwing
turrets up in the main Lane area around
a corner or something you know they're
going to get destroyed but they're going
to pull the team's attention away
they're going to do a little bit of
damage and when an enemy is focusing on
your turret they're not focusing on your
teammates who are shooting them yeah
it's a great way of just like closing
off one lane completely and almost like
pushing people to take another option
and then sort of allowing your team to
focus on that one area and that's
symmetric the latest hero on our
overwatch hero guides here on GameSpot
I'll make sure you subscribe to us here
on YouTube check out our playlist which
is featured at the end of this video you
can click on and see all the other
guides we've done and stay tuned to
Gainesville comm for more overwatch hero
bites on
you